channel is sponsored by Herman Miller
and Logitech G which means we'll have an
ad from them somewhere in the middle of
today's video which by the way was
originally posted on my personal Channel
but I decided to delist it and reupload
it here because I do talk about film and
TV as well as just video games here so
if you think you've seen this video
before you may have because it was
originally on a different Channel and is
being re-uploaded here a lot of people
like this one so I figured you guys
wouldn't mind here it is I'm sure
everybody thinks this of themselves but
because I tend to come to a place in
life in general of where can I find the
good in this thing I think I'm generally
pretty good at looking at media that
everybody else seems to hate without
like going in with that cloud I never
want to hate anything so with that in
mind I thought that I would do you all a
service and watch Velma a seemingly
unanimously hated show the left hate it
the right hate it HBO maybe likes it
because I think it's already been
renewed for season 2 because everybody's
hate watching it I don't know how many
instances there are of people hate
watching something so much that it gets
green lit for a second season but here
we are but in case you didn't want to
sign up to HB Max and hate watch Velma I
am going to watch it for you I've never
done a reaction to any kind of Animation
like this before so I'm making the
screen very small and I might have to
edit around it creatively not exactly
sure how that's going to go down on
YouTube's algorithm so we'll do our best
but this is it ladies and gentlemen
going in with an open mind I really like
miny King and I really like Scooby-Doo
it was one of my favorite shows as a kid
I generally think that HBO Max puts out
good stuff let's watch Velma my name is
Velma Dinkley normally origin stories
are about tall handsome guys struggling
with the burden of being handed even
more power wow that opening uh sentence
certainly is a a choice even from the
top to have my initial reaction to a
show be oh is it is pretty unusual
instead of saying hi I'm VMA and this is
my origin story here's what I'm about
certainly a pretense but all
right
Brenda yeah I like the environment a
actually is what I
like have you ever noticed how pilot
episodes of TV shows always have more
gratuitous sex and nudity than the rest
of the series Sex sells and in today's
overcrowded Market you need a hook so
this scene is um like a fourth wall
breaking reference to how many times
there is nudity in a pilot to sell
something while they're all nude it does
feel like this show is ranting at me
more so than it is telling a story thus
far and how do you feel about race blind
casting DNE well as an Asian woman I
um what
okay this is weird I understand a show
making some references to like current
sociopolitical issues that's actually
compelling content we like that
generally that's an easy thing to make
fun of so far it's every single scene
that's all they've done in in Velma the
only thing that they've done is is break
the fourth wall about race and and sex
and casting um so I'm at the point now
where at first I was like weird Choice
don't love it but okay I'm now like um
uncomfortable and we're only 2 minutes
and 33 seconds in so okay
Brenda wait did you climb in my locker
to prove how skinny you are again she
has no
brain who killed Brenda Velma you're not
real you're not real who isn't real
sweet premise uh God's not real if you
two morons are running this
investigation seriously how long has it
been since Daphne had you over to our
house uh since my mom went missing 2
years ago every day we're closer to
finding dad Dia her name is Dia you know
what I also think that Velma as a
character if maybe the the gist is that
she's supposed to be kind of unlikable
maybe I'm being too forgetting I'm a
suspect I thought lesbians were good at
solving crimes it's like the one
positive stereotype perpetuated by copes
Velma so TV
referential
um it's like whoever wrote this hates
TV which is okay
um but it's a weird thing to push on
your audience unless you're making a
show about TV I know that some of you
have noticed that something has changed
and it's true I finally got a new chair
a chair that is actually built for back
support and it is a game changer this is
the logitechg Herman Miller Phantom
gaming chair it is built for better
posture it naturally makes you sit in
the sort of forward active upright
position which is much better for like
literally when game for reaction time
but it's also a lot nicer on your back
if you're sitting upright you're putting
less pressure on your lower back like I
tended to do with my old chair and
you're instead sitting with a straight
spine and I feel like I am more
comfortable all throughout the day I
have way less back pain in general it
has a thoric support pad that works to
support your upper back neck and head
and then their posture fit system
provides adjustable support to your
lower back the headrest also just has so
many settings my favorite thing is that
the whole thing is just super adjustable
you can set like how much lean you want
like where you want the head to be what
kind of tilt you want on it and all very
very easily it also comes in three
colors I have the polar because most of
my setup is white but there's also the
red flare and the black obsidian it's
such a cool collaboration between Herman
Miller who are known for chairs and then
Logitech G of course who are known for
gaming so you combine those two things
and this is what you get I'm in love
with it thank you so so so so much to
Logitech G and Herman Miller for sending
me this chair that I now live in for
giving me the opportunity to tell all of
you about it you're back to deserves
better I'll leave a link in the
description to where you can check out
more about this particular share but for
now back to the
[Music]
video hey watch where you're going
jerk hey Fred I will say though um this
character of Velma is definitely very
different to the way that Velma ends up
in Scooby-Doo this may as well be a
completely different show but obviously
they need the IP to make anything these
days which sucks BR end me no I know I'm
Cente as this one's people would say no
Brenda's dead what no she was my plan B
if you ever got too clingy what happened
ask and then that was stupid that was
bad that was a bad joke that was
cringey dad you can't just eat soggy
fries from the takeout container Velma
that's not fair I'm not just a waitress
I'm also a basic who doesn't even
know how to use
hashtag right
my
pony that was Brenda's favorite song and
yeah normally in pop culture when a
girl is murdered we're all a
little like well maybe she
deserved they've done it again they've
done it again again a few of those jokes
are kind of likable like if you have a
few of them throughout a show in a way
that's self-aware and smart like I think
the way that um the first Knives Out had
the joke about like the one teenager
who's basically an Insel
I found that to be quite funny but when
you have it at this rate it's got to be
every minute where is the show in
between the the anger you got you know
you got to actually sell me on this
universe and not just on a series of Pop
Culture references that nobody talks
like that in the real world not that
like when you're trying to make a comedy
you have to be realistic but but
grounded in something other than making
it seem like you dislike working she
made my previous so-called best friend
look like a piece of crap uh
that was a weird scene so they they make
her get a job like her parents force her
to work as a waitress just so she can go
to a funeral where the funeral is being
held at the the din she waitress is at
just for her to throw it out and leave
weird Choice weird Choice I'm trying to
pull myself together so I can be the man
my father expects me to be Zam D City
sorry continue no I get it that was also
really cringey
Zam D city is a thing she just said that
I think was supposed to be
funny BMA there you are Norville what
the hell you didn't mym voicemails and
then my dad heard me call you
the why is everyone in this un of us
like this you didn't answer my VMS
voicemails What could would you not just
have one of them be insufferable like
that shaggy but I had to find you
because I still don't know if you listen
to my VMS voice mails let alone
responded did you yes and I I hated that
why have you done this on TV shows The
Malt Shop owner is always a friendly
black man or a spicy a meatball
Italian doing it again she once again is
being like and here is my commentary on
TV is it because they're like extremely
proud that they've hired
a brown woman as the lead of this
show and they feel the need to like
looat about it is that what's happening
why do you keep needing to reference and
hate other TV like this much are you
okay whoever wrote this oh okay few I
thought you were like suggesting a date
a date you
wish a date
what it's so obvious you know
that's well guess what Velma if you want
my boyfriend you can have him boyfriend
you think I want Fred I mean sure if
someone was like want to see a naked
picture of Fred I'd be like hubba hubba
but I'd say that about anyone
LeBron it's so weird have you given any
thought to all the other ways you could
die trying to solve a mystery Crush by
revolving bookcase attack by bats
falling off a fence wow I hate him I
really hate him Elma did you fall no I'm
cool and graceful like a swan okay cuz
it really sounded like you fell very
obvious jokes
again the Marvel quippy well it sounded
like you fell that they like just play
in every Marvel movie now muddy oh sorry
I'm not a drunk on the verge of losing
custody like every other woman solving
murders these days clearly I
hallucinated because I do still it's so
weird like that she's just clearly I'm
not a a drunk on the verge of losing
custody like every other TV writer like
there's supposed to be a rule in
Hollywood where you try not to like
on other shows like I guess that you can
you're allowed to criticize them
constructively and have conversations
about things you like and don't like but
this is just like over every
other like it really seems like they got
gripes they have gripes oh so it it
wasn't written by Minnie King it was
written by Charlie Grandy who is Charlie
Grandy
whoever this guy is Charlie Grandy
American standup comedian worked on The
Daily Show Saturday Night Live the
office Guys with
Kids he's worked with mini King on a few
things well apparently he is the writer
it's not like a full wrest room unless
it is I'm not sure but it sounds like
that's this just this one dude wrote
this who I'm not familiar with and I
guess it was not Mindy K interesting um
the show is not the worst thing that
I've ever seen
however it's very grating and I think
that's the problem that everybody is
having with it like constantly making
these like Jabs and trying to be woke in
a way that's just weird and awkward and
cringy and like doesn't serve anybody at
all there are some tiny bits that I
thought were like funny not in a way
that I'm trying to tell you that I think
the show is hilarious more in a way that
it's like I went in with really low
expectations and I'm trying to find
anything that doesn't just like play
into um a non-constructive narrative
that has already been established is it
funny in any interesting way majority of
the time no it's like very overwritten
and boring um and it it just really
seems like whoever Charlie Grandy is the
guy's either trying way too hard to be
woke or he's got some gripe with some
other TV show like I don't know dude did
you were you a writer on something else
and you got kicked off like I don't know